cela se passe dans un dojo et les
techniques ressemblent à celle du judo
pourtant c'est de lutte germanique dont
il est question un art martial pratiqué
au 15e et 16e siècle l'ct d'aujourd'hui
il travaille essentiellement autour d'un
d'un traité qui s'appelle le Codex
valeur Shine qui date du 15e siècle mais
moi je me suis focalisé sur la lutte
étant lutteur et un amateur de de lutte
sur ces aspects de lutte surtout parce
qu'il va distinguer deux forme de lutte
une lutte on va dire de jeu plus pour le
plaisir donc ça veut dire qu'on a déjà
ces notions de réflexion de jeu à épque
et aussi une lutte pour la vie donc
vraiment pour se défendre je prends un
peu de distance je viens là toute la
pratique des arts martiaux historiques
est basée sur une double ambition on y
vient pour le sport et parfois pour la
compétition tout en développant ses
connaissances pour une époque précise
l'idée c'est qu'on travaille de la DEC
de fiory donc fioret c'est un maître
d'arme merci c'est un maître d'arme qui
est fin 14e début 15e ça permet d'avoir
et un contexte historique ça c'est sûr
mais aussi de pouir travailler aussi bah
de la gestuelle éventuellement de la sal
défense ça c'est pour le plaisir parce
que on aime bien
hop merci les pratiquants sont plutôt
des trentenaires souvent nourris au jeux
Dr rôle et désireux de remettre au jour
un patrimoine connu d'une poignée
d'historien il passe souvent des heures
à étudier des traités de combat écrit il
y a trois ou quatre siècles nous ce
qu'on a ce sont des manuscrits ou
parfois moins que des manuscrits pour
ceux qui vont faire des disciplines plus
comme ce qu'on a vu ce matin du bouclier
Viking on peut faire que des
suppositions plus ou moins crédibles on
va nécessement devoir confronter à la
pratique et c'est cette pratique qui va
permetre de dire oui ça c'est
potentiellement vrai ça pas vraiment
donc c'est tout le jeu de
l'interprétation de la recherche
scientifique et de
l'itératif l'itératif la répétition des
techniques présentées dans les vieux
grimoir ouvre une autre vision de ces
arts martiaux historique celle de grands
enfants heureux de jouer à la bataille
avec des armes heureusement
ensible